what I learned many years ago
as is that we are not inspired by what
uh human beings are inspired by purpose
cause or belief were inspired by why
right
um very very few if any people are
inspired by the product the company
sells you know
um uh not a single person in your
audience not a single person in your
company is living their childhood dream
of one day selling sweet drinks
right nobody was 10 years old and says
one day one day right it doesn't exist
right
sorry but it's true
um
but when we say when we were our
childhood dreams is to work for an
organization when we feel like we're a
part of something bigger than ourselves
and contributing to something bigger
than ourselves and Coca-Cola going back
decades when that company when your
company is at its natural best and it's
not always at its natural best but when
you're at your natural breast you're
spreading happiness and joy
and we know that from your marketing but
most importantly you have to do it
internally as well there has to be
happiness and joy in the company
the customer will never love the company
until the employees love the company
first and so you can't be so dedicated
to spreading Joy externally if you're
not good at spreading joy into it
and by the way that is living your
childhood dream because for people who
are motivated and love working at your
company it's because they love making
people happy it brings them intense Joy
I just happen to be in marketing I just
happen to be in sales I just happen to
be in Human Resources but more than
anything I love making people happy and
is spreading Joy that's why I love this
company